F
SUSSEX AND THE PALACE.
BRIAN:  A LIVE LOOK AT THE WHITE
HOUSE WHERE CUBAN AMERICANS ARE
RALLYING TO DEMAND ACTION FROM
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AGAINST
THE COMMUNIST REGIME.
DAN BONGINO IS THE HOST OF "UN
FILTERED" AND CANCELED IN THE
USA ON FOX NATION RIGHT NOW.
DAN?
ARE YOU SURPRISED THIS OPENING
FOR THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES THAT HE'S CHOOSING NOT TO
RUN THROUGH IT?
A CHANCE FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
50 YEARS TO GET A COMMUNIST
REGIME OUT OF CUBA.
>> BRIAN, THIS IS THE BIGGEST
BUNT IN AMERICAN POLITICAL
HISTORY.
IT'S A BUNT.
NOT THE CAKE LIKE MY BIG FAT
GREEK WEDDING, A BUNT, LIKE A
BASEBALL BUNT.
THE CUBAN GOVERNMENT KILLS AND
TORTURES PEOPLE, HAS
IMPOVERISHED THIS GREAT NATION
OF PEOPLE DOWN THERE, JUST 90
MILES FROM KEY WEST, RIGHT?
AND TORTURED THEM, BEATEN THEM,
POLITICALLY IMPRISONED THEM FOR
DECADES.
YOU FINALLY HAVE AGAIN SOME
SEMBLANCE OF A FREEDOM MOVEMENT,
PEOPLE SPEAK OUT AND WHAT DO YOU
HEAR FROM THE WHITE HOUSE?
IT TOOK THEM WHAT, FIVE DAYS TO
SAY HEY, YOU KNOW, POLITICAL
TORTURE, BEATINGS, COMMUNISM,
DEATH AND DESTRUCTION, MAYBE
THAT'S A BAD IDEA.
FIVE DAYS?
IT TOOK YOU FIVE DAYS?
AND THEN THE DEMOCRATS, BRIAN,
OUTSIDE OF THE WHITE HOUSE.
YOU'VE HAD OTHER DEMOCRATS WHO
LIE FOR THE CUBAN REGIME.
OH, IT'S DUE TO THE EMBARGO,
THEY ARE PROTESTING THE EMBARGO.
THEY ARE?
BECAUSE I SPEAK A LITTLE SPANISH
IT'S NOT GREAT BUT A LITTLE
SPANISH AND THEY ARE SAYING I'M
REASONABLY, I GOT MY PODCAST,
THAT'S LIBERTY, RIGHT?
YEAH, HE SPEAKS SPANISH.
THAT MEANS LIBERTY.
THEY ARE RIGHT HERE.
HE CAN TRANSLATE.
THEY AREN'T SAYING, YOU KNOW, WE
NEED MORE FOOD.
WE NEED MEDICINE ALL ALTHOUGH
THEY DO.
THEY ARE SAYING LIBERTY, BUT THE
REASON AOC AND OTHERS AREN'T
SPEAKING OUT HERE AND LYING
ABOUT WHAT THEY ARE SAYING
LIBERTY, IS BECAUSE THEY ARE
SOCIALISTS.
THEY LOVE SOCIALISM.
IT'S AS SIMPLE AS THAT.
DON'T OVERCOME PLACATE INDICATED
BRIAN:  REMEMBER THE OBAMA
POLICY WAS REASSURE APPROACHMENT
AND THEY WANTED TO ENGAGE AND
THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE OF THAT
POLICY ARE IN THE POLICY
DEPARTMENT LEADING THE CHARGE,
CUBA AND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, THIS GUY JUAN
GONZALEZ EMILY MANDRELLA, BUT
LISTEN TO THIS , DAN.
IMAGINE IF CUBA HAD A
REPRESENTATIVE GOVERNMENT AND
THINK ABOUT WHAT THEY ARE DOING
IN VENEZUELA.
IN BOLIVIA AND LOOK AT THE ACTS
AND THE FACT THAT IT IS A OUTLET
FOR CHINA, AND FOR RUSSIA.
ALL THAT BE GONE.
THAT'S AN OPPORTUNITY YOU'D
THINK HE'D RUN THROUGH BUT LET'S
PIVOT.
LET'S PIVOT TO HUNTER BIDEN.
TURNS OUT EVEN CNN HAS A PROBLEM
WITH THIS ROOKIE ARTIST AND
MEETING WITH POTENTIAL BUYERS,
THAT COULD BE PAYING HIM UP TO
$500,000.
LISTEN.
>> I FIND IT HARD TO BELIEVE
THAT THERE IS ANY SUCH THING AS
A BLIND SALE WHEN YOU'RE
PURCHASING ART FROM THE
PRESIDENT'S SON.
>> DEMOCRATS ARE IN THIS
CONUNDRUM OF TRYING TO SAY
DEFEND WHAT HUNTER BIDEN IS
DOING WHEN THEY'VE SPENT THE
PAST FEW YEARS VERY MUCH
CRITICIZING FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
>> THIS IS A HUGE ETHICS
PROBLEM AND OPTICS.
BRIAN:  THEY SEE A PROBLEM.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION SAW A
PROBLEM WHEN HE WAS WITH BARISMA
IS HE TROLLING US?
IS HUNTER TROLLING US OR  HIS
DAD?
>> THEY HAVE TO BE.
THEY REALLY HAVE TO BE LAUGHING
AT US.
THEY HAVE TO BE SITTING IN THE
MOVIE THEATRE IN THE WHITE
HOUSE GOING YOU KNOW, GUYS?
THERE'S DRIFTING AND THEN LOOK
AT THESE IDIOTS LIKE LOOK HOW WE
SUCKERED THESE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I GOT TO TELL YOU I DIDN'T
REALLY THINK ABOUT IT THAT WAY,
BRIAN BEFORE THE SEGMENT.
I THINK YOU'RE ON TO SOMETHING.
I THINK THEY ARE TROLLING US.
THEY HAVE TO BE OPENLY MOCKING
US SERIOUSLY IF THERE WAS A
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL OF THIS ,
THIS GUY IS THE  MVP OF THE
LEAGUE.
I MEAN TALK ABOUT IT AND YOU
WONDER TO YOURSELF, DO THEY
THINK THIS THING THROUGH?
LIKE IF I'M CHINA RIGHT NOW, I
GET SOME CCP ASSOCIATED WETS IT
BUSINESSMAN TO OVERPAY FOR A
PAINTING.
I THEN LEAK IT TO THE AMERICAN
MEDIA, AND CAUSE LIKE A GEO
POLITICAL INCIDENT.
BUT OF COURSE, BECAUSE THE BIDEN
FAMILY IS TOO STUPID TO FIGURE
THAT OUT OR  THEY ARE TROLLING
US, YOU MAYBE RIGHT.
THEY JUST DON'T SEEM TO CARE.
THEY ARE EITHER TOO DUMB OR
LAUGHING AT US.
BRIAN:  ABSOLUTELY, DAN AND IT'S
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THIS IS JUST THE
BEGINNING AND BY THE WAY
WENDY SHERMAN THE NUMBER TWO
DIPLOMAT JUST GOT BE RATED IN
CHINA OVERNIGHT AND SHE'S
REPRESENTING OUR COUNTRY SO
THAT'S REALLY GOING WELL.
DAN WE'RE GOING TO LISTEN TO
YOUR RADIO SHOW FROM 12-3:00
TODAY AND NOT ONLY THAT WE'RE
GOING TO WATCH IT ON FOX NATION,
SO WE CAN DO BOTH THAT'LL BE
GREAT.
>> RIGHT AFTER YOUR SHOW,